For the first example, if we drive more miles in a rental car the cost will
usually go up. Now I know most rental car companies have a flat fee but some
also charge per mile and they might charge if you go over a certain number of
miles. So in general, if the miles go up the cost also goes up. So that must be
direct. The second example would be inverse let's say 2 people live together and
rent is $400 this would mean each person pays $200 but if we increase the number
of roommates let's say from 2 to 4 then people wouldn't pay $200 each they'd pay
less. Now instead of paying $200 each person would just pay $100. So as one
quantity increases, the other decreases, inverse. The second case is another
example of inverse. As the speed of a vehicle increases, the time that we have
to drive that vehicle decreases. And maybe you've never driven a car before. But
you could still think about this if you were walking. If we walk slower or drive
slower then that means our time would increase to get to our final destination.
One quantity is increasing while the other is decreasing. So that's definitely
an inverse relationship. This fourth example is an example of direct. If we
don't drive for a while, then we can't cover as much distance. So as one
decreases, the other would decrease. Likewise, if we drive for a long time then
we can cover more ground so this would be direct. For this last example if we
make more money then we can spend more money. So that will be a example of the
direct. If our arrows point in the same direction then we know it is a direct
relationship whereas if the arrows point in opposite directions we know it's an
inverse variation.